Republicans know that they didn't suppress
enough of the vote in twenty twenty.
If they had suppressed enough of the vote
in November, Trump would be president right
now instead of Joe Biden.
So Republicans have launched a nationwide
voter suppression effort.
It's already underway with two hundred and
fifty three different bills in 43 states.
Many of these bills premised on false.
Claims that Donald Trump actually won the
2020 election, now you have to give them credit,
they see the problem and they're trying to
fix it.
The problem is record voter turnout in November
gave the election to Joe Biden.
As they see it, too many people voted.
So the solution is to prevent people from
voting.
Now, all of these bills in some way.
Attempt to restrict voting in ballot access,
the Brennan Center for Justice has a great
analysis on this, and the playbook includes
strategies we're familiar with make it more
difficult to register to vote by banning voter
registration.
That's automatic by shortening registration
windows.
That's one part of the playbook.
Purge voters from voter rolls.
So they believe they're registered, they show
up and they're not.
You can do that by putting in place looser
and looser guidelines for when people can
be unregistered and removed from voter rolls.
Third part, make voter ID requirements stricter
and stricter, which we know disproportionately
impacts poorer people.
Now, how do they do this?
The way you do it, it's almost evil genius
in order to get the voter ID as free as they
say, but in order to get the voter ID, you
require more and more documents that you have
to bring with you to be given the voter ID.
And these are documents which poorer people
are less likely to have.
People with more housing instability are less
likely to have retained.
And some of the documents you need to get
your free voter ID costs money to get OK.
And they're documents that take time to get
when people can't afford to take time off
from work to deal with bureaucracy.
So that's how you deal with this problem of
too many people voting through voter ID.
Another approach is you add elements of voter
intimidation to voting.
You increase pollwatchers, that type of thing.
A few examples.
Georgia Senate Republicans have introduced
a bill that would end no excuse absentee voting
entirely, meaning you can't just say I want
to vote absentee because I want to.
They restrict the reasons that you can give
to vote absentee.
Georgia House Republicans have their own sweeping
bill, which would reduce the early voting
period.
Again, just shortened the days, the number
of days people can vote.
Montana Republicans want to end same day voter
registration.
Missouri Republicans want a new voter ID requirement.
New Hampshire Republicans want to ban out-of-state
college students from voting in New Hampshire
and they want to end same day registration.
Iowa Republicans already approved a bill that
would shorten voting hours on and on and on.
Now, at the same time that there are bills
proposed to limit voting, there are also bills
proposed mostly by Democrats to expand voting
access.
And hopefully some of those will pass.
But Republicans aren't even pretending.
They haven't been pretending for a long time.
They openly want to win, not by winning the
hearts and minds of people with policies that
voters will like.
They want to win by making it hard to vote
disproportionately for people that are statistically
more likely to vote for Democrats at some
point.
And I believe that that point is now.
The only way to deal with this is to pass
national election reform and to pass it in
a way that it overrides state limitations
that Republicans want to impose and to prevent
the next president from just undoing it.
Easier said than done, but is there any better
time to do it than when Democrats control
the White House, the Senate and the House
of Representatives for at least the next two
years?
The time to do it has to be now, and we'll
be talking more about what that effort could
look like in the future.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Let me know your thoughts on this massive
dump of voter suppression bills across the
country from Republicans